et que voit oui alors moi j'ai très
française un petit coup de gueule alors
quoi parce qu'évidemment on sent un peu
pareil mais on s'en doute qu'elle a fait
naître son enfant en france pour qu'ils
aient tous les soins français la
nationalité française et trois jours
après où une fois qu'ils nationale elle
part vivre à dubaï
menno meyjes à dire qu'enfin elle
habitait déjà vu à l'eau non non non il
aura pu vivre là il aurait pu naître là
bas donc la baleine société va gagner
son argent il va vivre là bas si fait
son âge qui serait pas non mais j'ai le
droit d'avoir cette habile à l'enfant va
être trop deux jours à paris la
nationalité donc quand tu auras un souci
un problème médical alors il sera
français est en revanche pour gagner du
pognon il sera à dubaï vous n'êtes pas
non plus j'apprécie moyennement la
démarche c'est le vrai débat qui
n'attendent qui naissent à dubaï mais je
hais ce que je suis le seul à voir ce
coup de gueule
non mais oui merci merci jean michel un
vrai bon alors ça peut passer le clair
et franc
oui la bouche chercher la paix oui non
beaucoup de gens veulent savoir si les
français juste ça et après ce bar
alors oui